[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Merry Christmas America
we're so glad you're with us thanks for
hanging out and if you're not in America
thanks for hanging out anyway open
phones at8
825-5222 today the one and only George
camell YouTube Star Ramsey personality
soon to be bestselling author of the new
book Breaking Free from broke that's on
pre-sale now wow I got a lot of stuff
crammed into your title there man thank
you I appreciate that you got a big
title today got a lot of stuff going on
this is a fun show one of my favorite
things to do ever is this show annually
we do a show on giving because we teach
you if you live like no one else later
you can live and give like no one else
if you follow the things that we have
taught you here for 30 plus years you
will follow a process that we call um it
starts with now you have to take care of
the now first take care of your own
household first or you're worse than an
un believer then then we once we get
past to taking care of now then we move
on and we start taking care of you know
the future then now then and and then we
say you know the future then we take
care of family we want to take care of
changing our family tree out past our
future into the future and then we move
on and we take care of community in the
world and you start talking about people
outside your family outside your future
outside of thing and and so as your
money evolves your vision for what to do
with it should evolve you should grow
shouldn't it absolutely Dave you talk a
lot about the myths that people believe
about wealthy people and rich people and
we say that you know if you're a stingy
rich person you know that those exist
but there's a lot more that are
philanthropists that's what we call them
when they're generous with their money
and we want to highlight some of those
stories as well and that's the kind of
stuff you can do when you have margin
and you follow the baby steps it's
inspiring yeah in today's world in a
capitalistic economy very few people
attain wealth without having the
character quality of
generosity because when you're
selfish versus selfless you smell
different
you have a stink about you and nobody
wants to do business with you nobody
wants to elevate you nobody wants to
promote you no one want you're slimy
when people meet with you they want to
take a shower after they're done if
you're that person it's very difficult
to prosper in our current modern economy
because everybody tells everybody it's
called social media right and so but if
you're a generous person um you know it
it's hard to deny generosity it just is
what it is and it changes who you are it
changes whether your smile it is much
more difficult to be depressed if you're
generous it is much more difficult to
get divorced if you're
generous very few people get divorced
they go you know that guy was just so
generous I couldn't take it I just
couldn't take it my husband was
completely he was unbelievably generous
it just drove me nuts that that's not
that doesn't come up in divorce decrees
you know haven't seen generosity doesn't
break much but it fixes a lot lot of
things it might break the bank if you're
out of control and you're dysfunctional
with it and you could do that but
generosity is what this show is about
today Mike is in Orlando Mike tell us
your generosity
story hey Dave hey George Merry
Christmas great to be with you Merry
Christmas how can we help well you know
I I was just a month or two ago I was
out of state at a restaurant and I had
never been there before and our server
was talking to us about how she had just
gotten this job because she was trying
to make extra money to pay off her debt
and her reason was because she had
recently purchased Taylor Swift tickets
and put them on her credit card it was
like a little over
$700 um she bought them as a gift for
her partner and she said they had a
great time but at the same time she had
these financial goals and stuff so
anyway we've been follow my wife and I
have been following your plan for a
while now Dave and um and so when I was
heing her story I started talking to her
about how important I thought it was to
get out of debt and you know I
encouraged her to do the same and she's
like yeah I know that's why I'm working
here so anyway um our bill ended up
being like
$42 um but I I ended up signing the tip
for like exactly what she owed on her
credit card which she had shared with me
was like
$710 cool
wow yeah you're more fun than a Taylor
Swift concert I'm just
saying well I mean and I never and I
never um she didn't know you know what
I'm saying so like I just signed the
thing for like
752 I get in the car and I guess my wife
could tell you know cuz she's like
totally on board with this whole thing
and um she I guess saw the look on my
face she go you paid her credit card off
didn't you and I'm like I I did babe and
she's like that's so so awesome we never
saw her again I mean I don't even live
in that state I checked I didn't even
know if it would work you know I checked
my um statement to see if you can give a
tip like that or you know whatever but
but yeah it worked so I was so super
thrilled and and uh you know I was also
with some other people at the table and
I didn't want them you know like when I
was talking to her about all this I
think they were like man this is weird
that Mike's getting into it with this uh
server about her life and whatever but I
mean they have no idea what what we did
and and I don't care that they ever know
but no it's not their business it's just
all of American the waitress and God and
your wife but yeah there you go way to
go man way to go that's is that fun and
it is and and I'll tell you we came from
$500,000 of debt W um and yeah so so you
make t Swift tickets look
smart wow I know man I me we we we had
we had a lot of stuff going on and so we
followed your plan got to baby step
seven so we dug out of half a million
and now we're just you know I I'm just
really excited about what God's doing in
our lives and and I just want to be I
don't know I I want to follow that and
I'm excited to to be a part of this this
team in the Ramsey scenario way to go
inspiring in a roundabout way he bought
a away Chris Taylor Swift tickets that's
how I see it in my head oh no I can't go
there but it's more exciting the
headline reads better he did not he did
not endorse the Behavior now he just
helped the poor girl who' made a mistake
oh that's pretty
wild the concert tickets or what led us
to this story of generosity listen going
to Tor Swift concert is not a mistake
going to tlor Swift concert if you put
it on your credit card and you're broke
and you're a waitress that's a mistake
okay by the way the tour is sponsored by
Capital One Dave so you know that's just
ironic I'm just saying
they're making their money back trust me
your partner in crime Rachel Cruz um
cannot be controlled on this subject I'm
just saying but aside aside from this
but yeah great job Mike way to go he
wrote that must have just blown her mind
yeah it's so fun she must thought oh
they missed they Mis wrote this I got to
take it back to them so that's what
we're doing Today's Show is the annual
giving show because God gave His only
begotten son and we celebrate it this
season that's pretty cool the OG Giver
so the OG Giver the original and so uh
check it out and we're going to talk to
people who've done giving all hour this
hour all hour the next hour and all hour
the next hour and we've got some really
special things we're going to add in
because I got to tell you there's a lot
of fun stuff you can do with money
Sharon and I just took this wonderful
trip we were 16 days in Egypt it was an
absolute blast luxury everything live
like no one else later you can live like
no one else buddy you tip somebody bucks
in Egypt you change their whole Networth
it's a lot of fun so I'm spreading
hundreds everywhere it was the most I
had more fun doing that than I did on
the trip trip was great but this is a
generosity hour it's the most fun you
can have with money and we're going to
prove it to you over and over for the
next few minutes don't you go anywhere
this is the Ramsey
shop
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the a
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today it's our annual giving
show thank you for joining us if you
have been the recipient of an
unbelievable gift or you were The Giver
of an unbelievable gift we invite you to
brag in either case because your
bragging is not bragging on you your
bragging is bragging on God and it's
encouraging other people 30 million or
so tuning into this the various formats
and platforms out there to become givers
and become generous so this is all about
inspiring additional generosity and to
that end one of our favorite people at
ramsy one of our own team members Is
With Us Melissa in guest relations works
on our team has for quite a while she's
standing on the debt-free stage to talk
about an
incredible uh Incredible Journey you've
been on hi kiddo hi how you doing Dave
hi George hey I have been so incred rly
blessed um my story starts back in May
of 2021 I was diagnosed with a very
aggressive form of breast cancer called
triple negative um I actually got the
call here at work that day uh the doctor
I mean you don't do just double negative
you go triple triple negative it's
pretty bad pretty bad the the doctor
called and said uh well Melissa this is
not really the news that we wanted
you've got a really aggressive form of
breast cancer it's called triple
negative he said don't Google it of
course I Googled it uh don't Google
anything tell someone not to Google
exactly that made me want to Google it
um that particular type uh has a high
recurrence rate fewer treatment options
uh real aggressive grows very fast so I
was here at work got that call
immediately I had prayer warriors around
me handson praying for me um the next
day the bunch of works as front lobby
with you that's kind of what they do yes
they do uh I'm I'm part of the most
amazing team guest relations uh Deana
cat Janelle Lindsay amazing front lines
Dave y um but anyway so the you actually
came out of the studio on a break from
the show I don't know if you remember
this you came out hugged me and prayed
over me uh that meant the world to me
knowing and you let me know you know let
us know what you need so fast forward a
few weeks I was about to go out to start
16 rounds of
chemo uh my team leader at the time came
out she said Melissa we don't want you
want you working while you're taking
chemo we want you at home getting better
um concentrating on that and I start
crying she said um your job will be
waiting on you when you get back I start
balling because y'all know I love my job
I got the best job out there um best
people and then she said Melissa while
you're gone we're going to pay you full
salary I just lost it I pray I mean I
cried so hard called all my family on
the way home I said you're not going to
believe this they're all crying we're
thanking God it was such a provision
from the Lord um so fast forward 16
rounds of chemo five weeks of daily
radiation a year of
immunotherapy um let's see surgery an I
had residual cancer I had to have
another eight months of seven or eight
months of chemo and you all didn't know
all that that I was going to be not even
steep foot in this building for a year
and a half we know it at the start start
but we knew it all along you kept the
day we were all we were all daily
checking in with you and you all did
nothing but encourage me pray for me um
I got so many texts calls um gifts at
home um get this on my e-year Ramy
versary I get a call from my team leader
and she says I'm laying in the bed I
just had chemo she said happy Ramy
versary eight years yay she said you're
getting a raise today I'm laying in the
bed I'm like who who does that who does
that Ramsey Solutions does so anyway I
was just so incredibly encouraged um
another part of this was uh my treatment
bills were very very high I mean we
David and I really did not know how high
they went it was um because I had all
kinds of you know some experimental
things happening but I never received a
medical
bill well I did but they were
miraculously paid
for and my um deductibles for like a
couple of
years who does
that well the the Lord provided for us
and we knew David and I knew from the
minute that I got the diagnosis the Lord
told me he said Melissa this is not
about you this is about me and how I'm
going to be glorified through it I'm
going to take care of you don't don't
worry you're going to be fine and David
and I locked arms with this whole prayer
Army I've got family and friends here
and my team here at work I mean and I
mean the encouragement was crazy David
my husband his nickname was coach
positive because he was he was coach he
was tough sometimes but he but my
sisters my friends I've got the prayer
warriors here my best friend that did
food I can't even say but Dave Ry
Solutions
was amazing through this this has been a
three three years of
hell I mean it'll it'll be three years
this kind hair grew back good isn't it
great mine didn't grow back good but I
didn't have cancer but I mean I kept
thinking if your hair grew back that
good there's a chance for me but there's
not but yeah I mean it really did did
you color it no this it's just
completely black wow it's awesome well I
did you know I had uh highlighted it for
a few years so I sort of forgot how dark
it was but I think it came back even
darker but um yeah I um but you know
Dave something that I learned through
this my husband and I we had many
conversations is if you hear of someone
in need make that call pay that visit
take that food even if if it's awkward
you don't know them that way it's always
awkward it's always awkward but but the
I'm I'm here to tell you because I've
been the recipient of it of people that
I don't really even know brought me food
food flowers gifts all kinds of things
and it blessed me and it helped me it
encouraged me and now through that
through all of this God has transformed
my heart in many ways I mean I was
walking with the Lord before but now me
and him are at a place I never thought
was possible but I will never be the
same as far as giving and doing for
others and I hate that it took cancer do
that you you were already that way
that's one re everybody love Melissa I
don't think they change you that much
but uh uh so but the end of the story
today is you're free well they don't say
that I'm cancer free they say I'm no
evidence of disease because of the kind
that I had um that they will wait uh but
each year that goes by the percentages
go down when I get to five years they
may say cancer-free but Dave I've been
healed they the doctors can say what
they want to say but I've been healed
and I know I have there's no current
signs there's no current signs I'm great
I'm out here I'm back I'm back to work
fulltime since November do a chemo
knocked the crud out of you yeah it did
I mean it knocked you down hard yeah it
did took a little while to come I mean
the Cure will kill you you know it's
like it it's nasty itad but you're
you're back and you're back to work uh
what three days a week or four Dave I'm
here every day eight to five you're back
five I knew we approved you to come back
for three but I didn't know you're back
to five you had to let your energy level
get back you right and I kind of had to
beg to I'm like y'all ready I'm ready
put me in coach put me in coach and and
you know and they were all so they all
cared about my health more than me
coming and feeling a place in here and
this guest relations team Dave y'all had
y'all were swamped in here in the lobby
and they all rallied they just did what
they had to do to take care of business
and it was you know and I've got people
out here I need to be sure and think
carried me to chemo appointments doctor
visits brought us meals encouraged me
when I couldn't get out of the bed um I
can't even name all their names it is it
is humbling to be the recipient oh at
this level yeah generosity coming from
every direction right um and you're too
weak to do anything about it you can't
stop it right exactly well we're glad to
have Mama mail back you said we
surrounded by Warriors but we've seen
your journey you are a warrior amen
absolutely and we are so happy to hear
the the journey and how well it's going
and good to have you back at full Mama
Mel at full force that's what we're
seeing today thank you Jesus and thank
you ramsy Solutions thank you so much
you are Ramsey Solutions kiddo I love it
beautiful well done wow this is how it
works George generosity at its best my
face hurts from smiling this is going to
be a long show for
me this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at CH Ministries .org
[Music]
budget still got
it welcome back to the Ramsey Show it's
our annual giving shows so we thought
we'd do something fun we got a couple of
hundred people or so in the lobby and uh
we ordered pizza for all of you woo so
Pizza just got here they look hungry and
now happy you need to go pay oh I'm
paying the pizza delivery okay I'll be
right back guys hold on go pay the pizza
go pay the pizza George and take care of
that cuz you know we don't want the
young lady to deliver pizza here and not
get paid that would be a a negative
thing on a giving show y'all want some
pizza y'all like pizza out there I want
some pizza I can't eat it while I'm on
the air my little legs made it Dave I'm
out here in the lobby for those you not
watch on YouTube what's your name
Marissa Marissa uh I'm I got to tell you
Marco's Pizza is my favorite this is not
sponsored I just absolutely love Marco's
Pizza well I'm glad you like it did you
bring me any cauliflower crust wasn't on
the order I'm just kidding it's it's
totally fine well how what's the bill
today you glutenfree Millennial
3476 okay
3476 uh I don't you know what I got 50
here and you can keep the change how's
that thank you Merry Christmas and you
know what I have extra change hold on
let me see if I can dig into these
little skinny jeans yeah I
got 1002 $1,000 is that
okay yeah that's fine that's for you
Merry Christmas are you serious I'm dead
serious oh my God thank you so much
what's the biggest tip you've ever
gotten um probably 170 bucks well now
it's a th000 you can tell the story
thank you so much are you absolutely yes
it's not even my money it's Dave
Ramsey's money so you have to take it oh
my God he's going to be okay oh my God
what so what's making you deliver pizza
is this for fun is it what what's going
on here well I'm just doing it right now
to fill time I'm going back to school
with APC for medical coding so awesome
so this a side hustle for you yeah I
mean it's something that it's pretty
decent money you know while I'm doing
today it's decent money that's for sure
oh my God yeah and I mean the
flexibility is nice it's not something
that I really want to do you know I
enjoy it I enjoy talking with people but
you know I'm looking into doing
something for my future that's well what
are you going to use the money on
probably pay off some bills that's nice
relief get some new tires um yeah that's
awesome any debt you on the journey to
pay off some debt cuz we can help you
with that too oh uh yeah but I mean
um we got you we're going to get you
taken care of with Financial Peace
University every dollar our budgeting
tool everything we can throw at you from
this bookstore it's on us
today I I don't even know how to respond
to that you don't have to here's the
thing here's your money I'll switch you
and I'll take the pizza how's that I'll
give it away to the nice people out here
in the lobby you're amazing do you want
to keep the bag oh I I can't keep the
bag that's Marco's property but I will
make sure you get the bag back to you
and we'll get all these nice people some
pizza and Merry Christmas on behalf of
Dave Ramsey and the whole team here at
Ramsey Solutions you're amazing thank
you so much thank you for you're doing
give it up for her guys
[Music]
yeah this smells really good I hope you
guys like it we we we love it we love it
already I love it we like it cuz you
brought it way to go man that's fun see
this is how you do it all you got to do
is just decide generosity Works uh
because it does it changes everything
and uh it will take your calls if you
want to call in George's handing out
pizzas out here give them a good shot of
that oh look at that thing oh look at
that pizza P maros just got a major
national promotion um that they paid zip
for and we paid for the pizza too I I
should have thought of this and told a
guy I want a pizza for free for a year I
just gave him that much so and she gets
the bag back very good good job George
Well Done you guys in the lobby give her
another round of applause well done very
cool who who where to go very cool well
if you've got a great giving story a
great receiving story we would love to
hear yours
has one she's in Asheville North
Carolina hi Molina tell me your story hi
um so my brother graduated high school
like a year early um so for his 18th
birthday that was coming up my mom is
like I don't know what to do for him all
he's doing is spending all of his money
and it's he's gonna end up nowhere and
so I recommended Total Money Makeover um
for him and so she got online and
ordered it used to try to save some
money and um brought it down there's
nothing cheaper than a used Total Money
Makeover book that's the cheap on cheap
yes and uh she bought one for herself um
and she knew that we have followed you
for years and that my husband and I are
doing well um so she's like will you
teach us will you sit down and do a
budget with your brother I was like yeah
so they came down for Thanksgiving and
he opened the book and he started
reading the first chapter and there was
$100
and my mom just looked at me and she's
like why did you do that I said I
promise Mom I did not do that and he's
reading and every chapter there was a
$100 bill so he ended up with
$1,300 in cash from Reading yeah pretty
pretty much he starts fast forward speed
reading at some point right no he did he
read the whole entire book at that point
like I I sat there and he read the whole
entire thing did she did you did she own
she put the $100 in there no she didn't
she she doesn't have it to put in it um
so she bought the used book and the
person that owned it before did this and
never took their money out yes I and
sold a $1,300 in a used book for 10
bucks or something it came from Thrift
Books I love it everybody's going to
Thrift Books right now and buying books
like crazy right so yeah he he read that
and we sat down and we did his budget
and he's in the construction union and
we like I'm like Bud you're on baby St
to three already this is wild so what
happened was somebody else's mother put
$100 in every chapter gave them the book
they took it down and sold it to Thrift
Books for $2 having never done what
their mother told them to do and then
your brother gets the book from your
mother used and is the beneficiary of
this this is whacked yeah my mom spent
like $5 on the book that's fabulous and
it wasn't the money wasn't easy to see I
mean it was in like the middle of every
chapter like really stuck in so you
wouldn't see it just like flipping
through it either yeah but how dumb how
dumb is the person that sold the book
and never read it that's the one that
you got to feel sorry for right oh man
that's hilarious but it just he went
from you know baby step one all the way
to he'll be done with baby step three at
the end of this month now and he's 18
years old and he
has you know it just it escalated it so
quickly but and he's he's on beat he's
going to do it now he's going to live
the way right yes yes he um he's taking
every out of state job that he can
because you make so much more money he's
like I don't have a girlfriend or
anything holding me down so I'm going to
just travel make all the money I can
save it as much as I can and he wants to
be a homeowner he wants to buy a nicer
vehicle so it's it's you got to love big
sister's uh rendition of this I don't
have a girlfriend holding me
down we're trying to keep it that way or
holding me back from my potential future
yes that is so great so he he the the
light bulb actually went on when he
finished the book and he's actually
going to go become wealthy because of
this yeah yeah he um he had kind of been
skipping back and forth through some
jobs um trying to find a good fit ended
up getting in with the Union but in the
middle of those jobs when to debt with
my grandparents because his vehicle
needed work on it wow um he just goes
through the drivethru all the time and I
we I'm like look at all of this money
that you are wasting on fast food and
stupid shopping that you don't need to
be doing and all the while you could
have bought a $5 book with 1300 bucks
inside
yes that is hilarious I love the story
oh mixed up generosity but it still goes
a long way that's fun very very cool hey
thank thanks Molina we appreciate you
sharing that this is our annual giving
show on the Ramsey Network on the Ramsey
show if you have a story where you've
been the recipient or you've been a
giver call us and let us know we want to
hear the story8
5225 we need to hear from you this is
inspiring it's hard to listen to this
day of broadcast on generosity not come
away smiling and not coming away going I
need to get out of debt and get on a
budget so I can do more giving because
the only way you're going to do more
giving is have more money I have noticed
that poor people don't feed hungry kids
have you noticed that rich people do so
you got to live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
[Music]
else
[Applause]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
it's our annual giving show here on the
Ramsey show George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host he likes to
say he has the spiritual gift of giving
away my money and uh last segment uh you
were you were Su you successfully did it
last segment $1,000 to the young lady
delivering the pizza what was her first
name again Marissa Marissa sounds about
right yeah all right and uh not my first
rodeo Dave I think it was first I think
it's safe to say she was a little
um speechless absolutely well number one
putting someone on the debt free stage
like that on camera when you're just
trying to in the middle of your work day
it's pretty jarring already I'm delivery
pizza is next thing I know I'm on the
camera and next thing you know here's
$1,000 I have no clue what to say and we
made sure I gave her a living give box
with your resources as well in there CU
we want to help her on her financial
Journey as she goes to school and gets
into medical coding and all that good
stuff so uh seriously you have been
giving away a lot of my money lately and
uh it was uh of course authorized and
encouraged uh it's a lot of fun lot of
fun the uh good good side gig though if
you good work if you can get it and um
uh uh you guys uh took the crew the
camera crew the some of the production
crew from the Ramsey Show and uh went
out in the wild and did a little bit of
this talk about and by the wild I mean
Antioch Tennessee and if you've heard
Dave for more than 10 seconds he's
mentioned his hometown there's nothing
wild about any Tennessee well back in
your day back in your day it was wild in
and it's wild now let's go to Dave's
neck of the woods and uh let's see if we
can bless some people out there with
some outrageous generosity and so where
do I go Dave I go to America's favorite
Diner establishment and that is Waffle
House the one and only through thick and
thin waffle is open you know the Waffle
House Index Dave you heard about this
more through thick than thin they use
the Waffle House Index to measure how
bad hurricane is if Waffle House is
closed we're all screwed that's
basically howad hurricane bad hurricane
waffle so they're out there Christmas
day you name it working their tails off
and so I thought let's go to Waffle
House and bless some people so here we
go let's play
it hey guys George camel here I'm
outside of a Waffle House in any o
Tennessee just down the road from where
Dave grew up and you know Dave is all
about outrageous generosity and it's my
spirit spiritual gift to give away
Dave's money and so that's what we're
going to do today in just a few minutes
we're going to cover everyone's Tab and
bless the weight staff with $500 each
and on top of that one special person is
going to get something extra so let's go
in and show them some outrageous
[Music]
generosity hello shatika how are you I'm
pretty good how are you good I'm ready
when you're ready shka I think that is
me okay I didn't know you have a signed
seating it's like yeah like section we
do mhm okay just can't have chaos out
here you got to have some order I'm
going to give you a coffee that's it
just a coffee that's it all right PL of
simple and you can give me the check
whenever you're ready just a coffee I'm
just I'm a little guy I got to keep my
physique you know what I
mean coffee is a diet yeah that's my
diet it all looks so good but I feel
like I'm going to be that's it for today
you're in a coma a has brown well no you
can do something white you know half
ground you know whatever that all sounds
heavy
yeah okay can I do
this hey guys quick announcement I'm
here on behalf of Ramy Solutions and
we're going to cover all your tabs today
Merry
Christmas cheers Merry Christmas it's on
us but you know what who do we have here
can I just go ahead and give you your
tip now before I run out of money cuz I
got cover all these people's tabs yeah I
didn't realize yall are slamming at this
this going I'll never financially
recover from this hey because you're
amazing your St is amazing here's $500
for you Bry thank you so much thank you
I appreciate that seriously well I feel
bad now I want to I want to do one for
for Crosby over there too whenever he's
ready there we go well Crosby Merry
Christmas man here's $500 on behalf of
Ramy solution wow God bless you all
right Ross Merry Christmas $100 on
behalf of Ramy Solutions we just want to
bless some people God bless y'all for
being out here doing the Lord's work
than you so Merry Christmas dude thank
you I got a kid on the way
congratulations I got a 2 and a half
month- old man I know how it is just uh
just found out last week so this is
congratulations man that's incredible
who are you guys going to spend it on
Bill Bill come on going something what
are you going to spend it on supp you're
an artist yeah that's awesome okay I got
to see your art after this that's
amazing that be awesome okay this is a
lot this all in 20s look how you're
bowling out here thank you Merry
Christmas thank
you I've just been going through a lot
and what's going on can you tell us
about it well last year um I have three
kids and last year I was I was shot in
my chest by my K dad and I just been
having a hard time and I really
appreciate oh I do we'll be praying for
you you're heing up good you better now
and how are the kids doing they they're
okay what's the ages 7 two and three wow
what are you doing for Christmas for
them I don't know just I'm just hanging
in here you know here you'll be working
on Christmas yeah oh my goodness thank
you well how about this you got all
those kids we need to get them some nice
Christmas gift don't you think how about
this cha we got something special just
for you we got an extra $2,000 to get
[Applause]
[Music]
you girl
girl we
chrm going through it going to bless you
with 2,000 extra dollars on top of your
500 thank you get those kids some
Christmas
[Applause]
gifts
can I come back there and hug you okay
I'm going to come back there and Huga
you're a warrior you're a hero thank you
for what you do every
day okay I'll pay my bill now y'all you
will not believe this I gave away my
last
dollar can I work this off in the
kitchen listen I'm like lad Del re yo
I'm doing it all right we're doing this
thing yeah usually I get to sit in front
of a camera and act a fool I'm actually
working at this the most work I've done
since I can remember 1 2
[Applause]
3 Merry Christmas everyone we'll see you
all right that's a wrap we gave away
thousands of dollars and let me tell you
there is no better feeling than giving
away money we always say that giving is
the most fun you can have with money and
you can see why the giver gets just as
much joy if not more than the receiver
and it's so special to get to bless
people especially around the holidays
people are going through stuff and so I
want to encourage you guys
you go give give a little until you can
give a lot go bless some people that's
the spirit of the holidays God bless and
Merry Christmas from Ramsey
Solutions there we go man way you go
George thank you that was fun well done
hey if that was if you're only listening
on audio and it was a little bit jumbled
pull it up on YouTube and watch it
because we captioned it and you'll be
able to read their the folks in in the
midst of dishes clanking and all the
other things going on the background
music the whole bit it's kind of hard to
hear some of it so pull it up on YouTube
you can watch it again and our team
clipped that on the highlights Channel
as well is its own video so that's a fun
way you can just go watch that one clip
on our YouTube channel okay just at the
Ramsey Show YouTube channel yes Ramsey
Show highlights channel it's right there
uh it's how I spent why I spent $5,000
on a cup of coffee the team titled it in
a fun way okay and that was a blast da
so thank you for having the idea of
saying hey we want to do let's do
something some crazy stuff for Ramsey
Show to just Inspire others to give
generously now behind the scenes I got
to know cuz I don't know uh did you all
know shatia story a little bit before
you got there all we did we asked the
management team said hey who's someone
who could really use some extra money on
top of that and they said shatia so I
did not know her story but that was but
out of everybody there that you were
already aiming at her I was aiming at
you didn't know why exactly and so I
said hey can you tell us what's behind
this emotion and she told us you can
hear in the video she was sh she was
shot by her baby's daddy wow I mean it
took my breath away when she said that
in the last year and so that's why I was
asking her how she's healing up and
she's got these three kids she's working
on Christmas Day and I thought let's
give these kids some amazing gifts um
and show them an amazing Christmas cuz
their mom is a warrior yeah and has been
through some things oh she's going to be
working on Christmas Day I mean come on
wow I hope they give her the day off now
but you know now she can afford it
exactly that day anyway so it was really
special and people were flabbergasted
that we were covering the tip which by
the way to cover the guy picking up the
menu and ordering after you said you
were going to cover everything was funny
wait wait right here right here he
started he started ready to order that
that one was great I like that that's F
you can cover the the whole bill at
Waffle House for 100 bucks y'all that's
something something fun to do this
Christmas 100 bucks will cover it I'm
telling you okay go do that now later so
what happened to the rest of the money
Jordan we gave it we did that three
times Dave that's for another video the
washing dishes to cover your bill was
cute that's a nice thank you that really
was work nice touch on I'm not used to
that a joke I'll have to wash dishes cuz
I forgot my wallet but you really did it
uh too fun this is a giving hour a
giving day on the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
la
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
this is our annual giving show where we
talk with people who have been the
recipient of generosity or they have
been the uh Giver of the generosity we
want to celebrate generosity because we
teach people to live like no one else so
that later they can live and give like
no one else my co-host this hour Ramsey
personality and author Jade washaw her
brand new book money's not a math
problem one of our quick reads it's a
quick read about what 40 50 pages here
something like that 57 to be exact you
can read it very quickly money's not a
math problem the real reason you're
broke and what to do about it available
for right now in the Ramsey bookstore
and she's my co-host today if you have a
giving story or a receiving story that
will inspire others we want to hear from
you the phone number Isle
88255 225 and I need to learn to pick up
the right line Briana is with us in
Austin Texas hey Briana welcome to the
Ramsey show tell me your giving story hi
Dave hi Jade I love you guys Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas so Dave I
called you a few years ago this is the
second part of my giving story this is a
Continuum um of my first story so back
in 2021 um well first off my husband
Ralph and I have been trying to get
pregnant for about seven years and we
were told by the doctor that we had to
go through IVF treatments fertility
treatments we started our debt-free
journey four years ago in October
started your program and so at the time
when we found out the cost we realized
we couldn't go back into debt for this
so um we were blessed my best friend and
his wife actually blessed us with
$20,000 um to go through these
treatments wow so that was part one of
the story so we went through IVF and we
realized it was a little more than 20 so
it was 30 so my best friend and his wife
said we got the extra 10 don't worry
about it wow so we went
through yes my best friend since high
school he is amazing um went through our
first round and unfortunately did not
have any viable embryos that we can use
so as you can imagine we felt completely
defeated um just devastated but I knew
to keep my faith and trust that God
would bless me with the desires of my
heart which of course is to be a mom so
Ralph and I obviously knew we didn't
have the money to do another round so we
said well maybe we should consider
adoption as an alternative well once my
best friend Dany and his wife found out
um of the outcome of the first round
they said no you guys are going to do it
again and they gave us another
$30,000 whoa to do another dang wow
which we did and we got embryos from
that and last summer we implanted one of
our embryos and I got pregnant but I
lost the baby very early on in the
pregnancy so again just you know try to
not question God right because knowing
he has a plan oh this is a roller
coaster of vicious emotions though yeah
it truly was um so it took me about a
year to heal from that loss and so a few
months ago I told my husband Ralph I
think I'm ready to do another transfer
and Dave and Jade by the grace of God we
are pregnant
W That's so exciting yes we are pregnant
we're almost 11 weeks we have a
beautiful healthy baby boy growing and I
just still can't believe it and we will
be debt free by January
hey well now there's some interesting
timing God's timing right always his
time his
plan wow wow wow well congratulations
and what an unbelievable friend I that's
what I'm thinking yeah he is a blessing
him and his wife will be the god parents
of our son obviously so and anything
else they want oh my gosh yes abolutely
amazing oh man that's has been I mean
seven years right up and down and just
so much emotions but I just I wanted to
come on and and share the second part of
the story just to remind people to never
lose faith in God's plan never lose hope
because you know he takes you through
it's never a just a solid line right
there's Hills and Valleys and it's up
and down and at the end of the day he
always blesses you with those desires
it's just trusting his time and staying
faithful wow and and then I'm sure for
you this also informs okay you're
debt-free this is going to inform how
you live like no one else right because
you've seen how people can bless other
people I'm sure that this you've already
got some ideas cooking on how you would
want want to be a blessing if I'm not
wrong right Jade 100% 100% and our son
will never know the word debt ever wow
that's incredible thank you pretty
pretty amazing so your friend um yes
extremely wealthy he you know what he
became a multi-millionaire just he works
for an organization that kind of blew up
when they went public a few years ago
and he's been there since they started
up and he cashed in his stock
I mean my friend never went to college I
mean he this was just a tremendous
blessing so he and his wife are
multi-millionaire that's it's a full
gift like there you don't have to pay
them back wow wow wow no not at all and
we live we we're from the Bay Area we're
from San Jose California but moved out
to Austin about seven years ago and so
he and his wife will be throwing a
shower for us a baby shower in
California with all of my friends and
family in a few months so that'll be
amazing very cool I love that yeah go
back home for that yeah or back to the
childhood home anyway way to go and I
will be there in Tennessee next year
we're going to come out and do our debt
free scream we've met y'all when you
came to Austin um for your event a few
months back so we will be out there to
do our debt free scream for sure and who
knows maybe the baby will be here by
that time and you know we can come in
you can meet him I love that I I would
be honored that that's pretty incredible
uh because one of my favorite things
other than generosity is
babies babies as they grow up and want
cars and tuition but um other than that
they're
awesome that's good Dave no the little
tiny ones I've got I love them but you
know and then then then they hit about
two and I let the parents take care of
them and then uh you know we had like
the seven-year-old the 8-year-old
10-year-old over last night for you know
Watching Elf that that's the right age
they've got they're you know they're
starting to um be able to reason with
them that's true you want them to get to
the age where you tell them what to do
and they do it
hypothetically yeah I love it don't do
that to the dog you'll kill the dog
don't do
that that's funny when Sam and I found
out we were having our first son uh we
did the little gender reveal and my
pastor leans over and he says oh it's a
boy that's great you don't have to pay
for the wedding that's the first thing
he started thinking about wow wow not
even had the kid yet they're already
calculating this this is great yeah too
fun too fun well done you guys very very
well done I love it hey that's what it's
about generosity it is more
fun giving is more fun than anything
else you can do with money now you can
do some really fun stuff with money uh
and you can do some bad giving sometimes
and it's not that fun but it is your
best option at creating a lot of smiles
and that's what we're doing today we're
highlighting and
inspiring receiving and giving any form
of generosity that we can come up with
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always always free see why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 40% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
Jade washaw Ramsey personality
host co-host of the Ramsey Show and
author of the new quick read that we
just put out money's not a math problem
y'all be sure and pick it up and check
it out she's my co-host today and uh has
also been a little bit busy in the last
few weeks in preparation for this giving
show today uh you were out uh George did
this too and uh we tried to get a couple
other folks in on it but you and George
were the ones that pulled it off um out
exercising spiritual gift of giving away
my money that's right that is the
spiritual gift it's easier when it's
someone else's money well if you if you
just remember you don't own it God owns
it you're managing it yes it leaves
everyone in that same seat you're giving
away someone else's money and it's
always easier to give away someone
else's money that's a good point that's
philosophical Dave I like that there you
go theological too watch out I'll get
you with both of them all right so you
guys went out with the film crew and and
talk up set this up a little bit what
what all happened so we went over to um
I guess we were on what the east side of
town James it was more like north side
like germant toown the Nations area Okay
the yeah the North Nashville and so we
found a Kroger over there and we thought
it'd be really cool if we could find a
way to give away groceries to folks and
so it kind of we wanted to be sneaky
about it we didn't want them to know
that that's what we were there to do but
at the same time you have to kind of let
them in a little bit because you have to
get them to sign a waiver so that can be
on camera and so what we did is we told
them that we had a YouTube show and that
we wanted to get their uh opinion on
inflation and Rising costs at the
grocery store and so that's how we got
them to talk to us and then we kind of
and you got them miked up that way and
so on yeah cuz I know it's the one lady
when I was looking at had a mic on I'm
like how'd you get a mic on yeah well we
tricked them we tricked them then we
blessed them all right I love it all
right let's roll it and see what
happened hey what's going on guys I'm
Jade warshaw one of the co-hosts of the
Ramsey Show look look we're always
telling you the most fun that you can
have with money is to give it so we are
going to put that to the test we went
over to our local Kroger grocery store
and we're going to see just how fun it
is to give some money away I came into
Kroger grocery store and I told Amy that
we really just wanted to know her
opinion on inflation and grocery store
prices but Amy what we really want to do
is just tell you to fill up your cart
and we would love to bless you with
whatever you can fit in that
cart what actually I just excited I
think I just want to buy you guys'
groceries today yes are you kidding we
have a really cool Christmas basket over
here that we'd like you guys to just
fill up with whatever you want we got to
call my mom and ask her what she wants
what am I going to do I want to get meat
yes get meat get the most expensive
stuff anything yes get what you want
girlfriend we are filling these carts up
this is so fun oh we just need two no
you don't you need lot maybe that's what
you guys want us to do my kid uses these
my baby eats these yes get plenty for
the baby I know things I've been wanting
to buy and hadn't been able to buad yes
look she's doing the right thing she's
just throwing it in the
cart this is great what YouTube channel
you guys work for so it's called the
Ramsey Show Dave Ramsey H okay I took
his class last semester oh wow
foundations and personal finance wow
yeah the de uh the debt snowball effect
that's the one I'm currently using right
now and it's help I mean it's help I
just came here to grab some lunch on my
lunch break where do he work we provide
insurance and things like that for
families of lower income housing or
whatever it may be that they can't
afford 10 care provides insurance
usually okay where's your card at it's
back there I was scared I wasn't going
to get it around here time Harold me
pushing your cart wasn't part of the
deal
now where you guys from uh we're from
Kenya okay cool my mom's from Somalia I
was born in Kenya he was born in Kenya
so you've got another younger sister is
it just a four of you guys I no it's 10
of us 10 of us wow I love that that is a
giant family this has been the funnest
Day of My Life free food
y'all who is sponsoring this is what I
want to know got it y God is definitely
God is you're right Amy you did it oh my
God i' say that's a pretty cool cart
good job what is this for cuz we just
want to be generous and this is what
we're supposed to do we're supposed to
bless people and you were so kind to me
when I rolled up on you in the
aisle I hope this was a blessing I'm
glad to see it is this is not going to
be a pretty face for
camera blessings on
blessings
all right two weeks of groceries for 388
75 but we're also feeding a family of
what 11 how long do you think this will
last you you're good minut yeah two
months good several months we have to go
to the store for a while Merry Christmas
bless y'all thank you Carol now how do I
get these in my car all right janaa we
did not forget about you cuz you have
been the one like ringing up all these
groceries and honestly watching all
these people get a blessing Merry
Christmas $500 I hope that you can find
something really great to do with that
we just hope that you have a Merry
Christmas yes
girl wow guys that was so incredible
look the cliché says it's more blessed
to give than receive and I can attest it
is so true that is the most fun with
money that I've had in a really long
time so look this season if you haven't
had a chance go and give go bless
someone's life it will truly be the most
fun you could ever have with
money wow wow that was a good time that
was a good time Dave how long were you
in the store total uh maybe 3 hours wa
okay going get all set up and then well
I think here's what I found three hours
to fill those buggies it was I feel like
it was yeah it was it was maybe like two
hours two and a half but the first the
first one took a while and then we
started saying all right you have 10
minutes and that helped move things
along I oh okay so they weren't all at
the same time we had to put them on
rning back to back to back oh I see we
had to put them on a Time the edit makes
it feels like they're all together okay
yeah it what I found was when you first
say hey go fill up your cart there's
like this moment of this can't be true
yeah and then it's like well I'll just
get a little bit and I'm like no it in
fill up the cart yeah everything you can
get in this cart we're paying for today
that's right and uh it took him a moment
and finally it clicked in it's like oh
I'm getting crab legs and I'm getting
like steaks like cuz they were grabbing
little stuff I was like guys you don't
understand the blessing here like we're
using money don't buy cereal it takes up
too much room that's right so oh that
was a good time so so fun that's fun
that's very cool well done well done
gang it's a lot of fun it is uh it is
the most fun you can have with money it
is I mean we say it over and over and
over again but when you experience that
uh secret santa type of thing where you
just walk up and randomly blow
somebody's mind fill up their uh gas
fill up their tanks with gas I mean when
we had the fouchy pandemic thing going
we uh sent a bunch of our team over um
to to two of the hospitals the local
hospitals to the gas station next door
and all the nurses and techs and docs
that came up when we're filling up with
gas we paid for their gas filled up all
them car it was a lot of fun lotun much
fun because they were on the front lines
there was so much tension in the air and
fear in the air in those days and
everybody thought you know we're scared
of other human beings all this stuff and
you just went out there and started
putting gas in somebody's car all of a
sudden everybody chilled out yeah you
know I would agree with that it was cool
in the store because you know that was
four four folks that you saw getting
blessed but there was a lot of people in
the store watching that happen and there
was this older guy who walked up to me
he goes what are y'all doing you're
giving away free groceries I said yeah
and he said well what do you have to do
to get them and I said well you know you
have to be willing to be on camera and
he was like okay well I'm not willing to
be on camera and it just so happened
that when it was time to check out the
two ladies he was right in front of us
so we were able to get his groceries too
and I said look you're here let's just
get your groceries too you don't have to
be on camera I said but and so I I was
just so happy the way it worked out
because and then of course there's the
cashier she's ringing up everybody and
she's watching all these people get from
the law what was the deal I don't know
he didn't have his hair done that day I
don't
know people get weird about being on
camera but it was fun that the way the
day worked out he ended up being in line
with us and and he you know got to
benefit from that too so it was fun
that's neat very very fun all right
folks that's how it's done and that's
what we're going to do this hour we're
going to take your calls from those of
you that have experienced generosity on
either side you've been the recipient or
the giver and it's inspiring to lift up
other people and cause them to do it
that's what this uh this particular
version of the Ramsey show is all about
this is the Ramsey
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is our annual giving
show where we highlight generosity here
on the ramsy show uh just a note for a
programming note for all of you if you
want to go back and watch some of the
videos of Jade or George giving the
stuff giving money away and blowing
people's minds it's a lot of fun or any
parts of the show uh you can certainly
do that on YouTube and in some cases
you're going to get the visuals and uh
we uh subc captioned it so you can read
because there sometimes background noise
or or the background music we put over
it made a little hard to hear in C
certain audio settings so go check the
YouTube out and you can watch it and
that way you can rewatch it if you want
to that kind of thing it's very easy
it's on the Highlight or the U what do
you call that section yeah the
highlights Chann highlight section on uh
the ramsy show YouTube
channel which by the way there's 147
million YouTube
channels literally y'all believe that
that's crazy is it that's a lot and they
sent us a note this week that the Ramsey
show or the Ramsey Network YouTube
channel is number
1,55 wow out of 147 million I mean I
don't know when being in the top th55 is
is a big win but in that case it might
be I think that it is I think that's a
huge win speaking of big wins on the in
the lobby on the debt free stage is one
of our Ramsey team members with a great
generosity story Lily is with us Lily is
on the real estate team at Ramsey
trusted working with real estate agents
Across America how long youve been with
the team Lily uh 45 days about oh wow
fairly Newby then okay good all right
cool so welcome and you you step forward
we put out a note to our team and said
if any of you have great generosity
stories you want to share on the air you
can and uh Lily step forward this is a
special story I've already heard a
little bit about this and so I'll turn
it over to you thank you so in Middle
School uh my parents divorced and my dad
ended up taking a job opportunity um
several states away knowing that he
would be able to still fly in and see us
um over the weekends or fly us to see
him so we remained close to him he was a
very special part of my life um and fast
forward several years he decided he
wanted to move back to Nashville and be
closer to my younger brothers um to
finish out their basketball games and uh
finish out their younger years um not
every other weekend but more often
throughout the week and he mov moved
back um as he was getting closer to
retirement age he was about 50 and um
about 2 months later he was diagnosed
with glol blastoma which is a very
deadly brain
cancer yeah um it was a big blow to the
family and um we all researched it
quietly on our own and though we tried
to remain positive we knew that it
likely meant he would be leaving us so
um how old were you I was let's see I
was in my early 20s okay 20 right um so
I was in college actually at the time um
I had just transferred from school in
New York to back home which is a God
thing and so I was at the University of
Tennessee in Knoxville and um as he was
sick would come home regularly to help
um every single week with this type of
cancer he would lose more ability to
speak ability to understand words and
more of his personality and so it was
every week a new version of my dad that
was a little bit less which was really
really hard to endure yeah um and so
during those months as times going on I
realized I was very single at the time
um but being so close to my dad I cannot
imagine a day where hopefully I get
married and he's not there and my
husband doesn't get to hear from him
meet him um and
I think a lot of girls want their dad to
be able to walk them down the aisle so I
felt a little nervous about it I didn't
want to suggest that I thought he was
definitely going to die but knowing that
it was a very real
possibility um I talked to my stepmom
about it and she thought it was a good
idea so we um started kind of trying to
turn the wheels and a girl that I grew
up with in Middle School sorry
Elementary School um her and her brother
had grown a very successful wedding
videography business in town and I
reached out to them uh full intent to
pay for a wedding video I think their
wedding video start at 10,000 wow um so
you were going to do a wedding video
with your dad but you were not engaged
and weren't dating anyone yeah we just
wanted to recreate um a moment just to
put that um just to have that in the
memory box yeah and the reason I wanted
it to be filmed I wanted it to do it for
two reasons one reason most importantly
for my dad and I to just have the
experience um it's something he wanted
it's something that I wanted and in case
we didn't get that chance um but two a
video to be able to share uh something
that's Timeless um if that day comes
where I'm married or getting married and
he's not here and uh after talking to
them they wanted to do it and they were
booked for pretty much the whole year I
was about to travel abroad to Italy and
my dad was declining uh again every week
and I felt he was still in pretty good
condition at that time but I felt for
some reason like if I wait it's not
going to be soon enough MH and so um
they said they wanted to do it they
wanted to gift it to us wow which was
huge that's a big gift that's the
generosity play okay we wouldn't have
been able to they gave you their
services yeah they filmed it um
themselves they actually have two
sections of the business and one is them
and one is some people that they
basically contract out um and so they
put everything together we also had a
family connection um that own a wedding
venue uh so Allen Brook Farms and they
gifted us their venue so there was a
wedding that was going to be on Saturday
and everything got set up early on
Friday another God
moment um and everything was gifted the
flowers were gifted um wow yeah and so
we got to have this moment um together
which was super special and then I went
away to Italy came back my dad had lost
a good bit of his
personality um and we got the video back
we sat on the living room couch watched
it together and cried
um yeah I'll never forget that moment
and still single still not sure when it
would be used but a moment that we got
to have together wow that's beautiful
wow yeah fast forward um to last year
and I'm about to get married so this
experience was about 5 years ago and
then um got engaged and last
October um we had everyone at um our
wedding venue which was also gifted
since my dad wasn't able to help provide
for the wedding MH um um and we had a
projector up and instead of doing the
fatherdaughter dance we played this
video and my husband got to watch it for
the first time with me it's really cool
wow yeah wow so it felt like my worlds
were colliding I remembered the moment
that I was in there and even though my
dad was gone it felt like he was there
with me a little bit um he was yeah yeah
beautiful goodness wow
beautiful lots of generosity makes a
tragic really sad thing a precious
memory yeah exactly transformed it yeah
something I wouldn't have gotten to have
and share yeah wow yeah otherwise wow so
was there was the videographer who
gifted their services then you even got
the wedding venue MH and they were fre
exactly yeah and it was just such a God
thing they both had the same Friday
available and basically no other day of
the year wow um so everything was just
lining up quickly it was like a week
before I was studying abroad again I
just felt um an urge to do it
quickly and um yeah Dallas Wilson
wedding films wow and um yeah they
gifted it to us and so thankful oh
that's a CO yeah pretty cool pretty cool
generosity story it's tragic and sad I'm
crying with you but uh wow powerful
powerful no no better use for
money the best use you can have with
money
generosity there's nothing that does US
good well done well done thanks for
sharing Lily good work this is a giving
show on the ramsy
[Music]
show
it's our annual giving show on the ramsy
show thank you for joining us if you
live like no one else later you can live
and give like no one
else Jade washaw Ramsey personality is
my co-host of the day today's giving
story of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
when you want to repair maintain or
improve your home stop wasting time
scrolling through pages and pages of
providers neighborly is all you need to
remember for a nationwide network of
local Home Service professionals visit
neighborly
docomo find Reliable help near you
today's question comes from Kate in the
United Kingdom I'd love people to know
that giving does not have to Cost a
Thing If you are not wealthy like me you
can still give your time your skills
your attention to others I volunteer
with age UK and have weekly phone calls
with older people who are lonely and
want some company I am so lucky I get to
learn about the era about them and I
really enjoy it I also walk around our
local park with someone who is lonely it
doesn't cost a Bean whenever they want
and I'm not working we go for a walk you
can give you can make a difference and
it doesn't have to cost you if you're
struggling financially absolutely not
winning that right there love that love
it generosity is not a dollar amount
it's a character quality uhhuh and
generous people are the ones that hold
the door for you they're the ones that
smile um they're the ones that um go for
a walk around the park with you that's
right I love that and they're the ones
that also give you a million dollars to
feed hungry children all of that is
generosity yeah I was always taught it's
uh your time your treasure and your
talent that's what you can give three
T's that's it Lauren is in Louisville
Kentucky hey Lauren tell us your giving
story hi Dave hi Jade Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas to
you okay so um we're kind of still in
the middle of our story um but to just
kind of go back a little bit uh my
husband lost his job after 15 years at a
company and uh we found ourselves door
dashing 10 hours a day to um try and
survive and so we went to our church
um just to see what they could do or
what they could help with which is a
really humbling experience and um of
course they were there for us and we um
we got gas cards and grocery cards um
but then one day I received a text from
one of the women that was working with
us and she asked me to come in to church
early one day just to tell our whole
story which is actually rather pretty
long um and so I went in and I thought
she just being super sweet and told her
the whole story and she asked what you
know what I needed and and at that point
I was so thankful for the gas cards and
the um the grocery help that they were
providing and and honestly I just wanted
prayer and I I really just wanted
somebody to talk to you know somebody to
kind of be alongside of us through our
journey um and so that was it we hugged
and I I went to church service and left
and went back home and um I don't know
if it was a a couple weeks later uh we
received another text that asked my
husband and I together to come into the
church and to meet with the pastor um at
our local church and her as well and we
had no idea what to expect so we went in
there sat down and found out that
somebody had given the church
$50,000 to manage to bless somebody that
was in our shoes wow that yeah and it
was um it was split between our family
and another family who was in need and
um so we received
$25,000 um that's a lot of money it is a
lot of money it it you don't you don't
know what to say or how to react in
those moments um I mean that's a that's
a fully funded emergency fund for some
people that's a lot of money it is it is
um they so whoever we we don't know
still to this day um we we have one
month left at this moment of um help and
we're so thankful for that but we um
they we don't know who it is and we're
not supposed to know who it is um but we
know that a little bit of their story is
just at some point I think the this is
an older couple they had the same thing
happened maybe they lost a job almost
lost their house and somebody did this
for and all these years later they are
really successful um I've heard they've
had some health issues and but they
wanted to um return and do the same
thing and uh Dave and Jade I have to
tell you um we when all this happened we
were debt free because we follow you
guys we did have a three-month emergency
fund that um helped us through at the
beginning before we went to the church
and um the day will come when we do this
exact same thing I know it will amen
yeah ability to pay it forward will be
incredible yeah my goodness well done
wow somebody well done out there good
stuff good stuff now how old were you
all when all this
happened uh 30 so around 35 it's been
about a two-year Journey that we've been
on husband's gotten a job now he he does
have a job it's not I we don't know
what's happening but it it's not even
enough still to pay the bills we went
from a six figure income to just I mean
almost losing our house and we have
applied I mean Miracles have happened
non-stop um I somebody paid for actually
our preschool paid for all our Christmas
gifts last year for our kids uh when
taxes were due because we we just work
nonstop I opened a dog business which
has been really successful in my home
and we plan on expanding it but we're
just like scraping by still but we've
never missed a payment on anything wow
um and we we um we don't play the
lottery I always listen Dave cuz you
make fun of your daughter for going on
vacations and you know gambling and
stuff well we don't gamble but my
husband got some numbers in his head and
bought a $2 lottery ticket where you had
to put the numbers in on a on a random
day and won $110,000 and after taxes it
was enough to pay our our taxes for the
year which we didn't have that's wacky
that's crazy it's been n stop I I don't
even know how to explain it wow what a
story way to go thank you for sharing
it's amazing thank you very much 20 a
gift of $50,000 to the pastor they say
find two unemployed families that are
struggling give them 25 each or that's
how the pastor decides split it up
anyway and uh pretty pretty incredible
it's makes all the difference in the
world thanks for sharing your giving
story Lauren very well done very well
done it's interesting how she said it
was probably a couple who had been
through something similar and it's funny
how when you go through a hard time
that's what informs how you want to give
later on because you've experienced it
you felt it you you felt the need and so
you feel obligated and you feel I mean
really obligation is not the word but
you want to help out in that same area
well you're inspired by people that are
feeling the same kind of pain you want
you know that's that's the thing so yeah
there's nothing wrong with that at all
no I mean if you if you've been through
uh can then you know you're have AA spot
for people that are going through cancer
whatever it is you're going to always
have that and that that that's perfectly
fine by the way that's one of the things
with the Ramsey Family Foundation we we
uh don't give to things that at least
one of us don't have one member of the
family uh doesn't have some kind of an
emotional connection to you have to it
doesn't have to be that we necessarily
felt that kind of pain but this is
something that's on our heart it's not
just generally we're looking at the
numbers and we just try to randomly
figure out oh these people are doing a
good job no we need to have a feeling
about it needs to connect to us yeah I
get and um cuz we don't give to that
many different things we do well with
the ones we do give to but um you know
one of the one of the analysis is does
somebody in here in the Ramsey family
when we're sitting and talking about
this does somebody in here have a
connection to this and I mean does it
does it does it prick your heart does it
make you come alive to say we want to do
our generosity that way that's right and
there's nothing wrong with uh avoiding
something that is perfectly valid but
that doesn't motivate you yeah of course
yeah so lots of very cool stuff out
there lots of things you can do to be
randomly generous or very intentional
and uh diligently generous by the way I
suggest you do
both you don't mess up with generosity
you can't get you can't outg give God
boys and girls you just can't do it it's
impossible Jade washaw good hour thank
you for having me this is a giving show
on the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build weth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
George camel Ramsey personality soon to
be number one bestselling author of the
book Breaking Free from broke book comes
out in January you can pre-order it now
he's my co-host today is a special
version of the Ramsay show it's our
annual giving show where we highlight
generosity and giving and uh if you're
just joining us uh go back and pick up
the other hours on uh YouTube or uh well
probably today especially on YouTube
because you're going to want to see the
videos of some of the generosity stories
that we have featured and uh just a lot
of fun so if you have a generosity story
that you are the recipient of inspiring
generosity or you were The Giver of
inspiring generosity we want to hear the
story because we want to hear Let a
whole bunch of other people hear the
story because uh this stuff is
infectious it's contagious it really
it's weird how watching stories of
giving makes me want to give and I know
there's there's a lot of psychology
behind that but I think we need more of
that in America today yep that's the
antidote to a whole lot absolutely so
the phone number if you've got a great
giving story
5225 you jump in and we'll do that
interesting uh the folks over at Mama
Bear legal forms that we endorse yeah to
do your
will they um since 19 Ramsay fans doing
their Wills with Mama Bear have left
million in charitable bequests through
their mama bear Wills altogether users
have given or pledged
15,1 186 gifts wow that's
mindboggling wow that's crazy that's
called leaving a legacy right there
that's not just leaving money to your
heirs that's talking about a gift
to some kind of um institution or some
kind of work of some kind right wow and
that's also pledged so there's people
you know if you have not passed yet
that's still pledged to be a part of
that as part of your passing which is
really that's inspiring it's crazy makes
me want to relook at my will and go hey
what are some really cool ways to give
361 million George that that wouldn't
even get you started I'd love to RI
people up long after I'm gone I'm still
making people upset and making people
happy at the same time Shane is in
Colorado Springs Shane tell us your
giving story yeah thank you so much for
all you do for the American people and
even the people of the world you're both
absolutely American Heroes just wanted
you to know that you're very kind Merry
Christmas to you Shane oh Merry
Christmas to you too sir so last year my
friend Andrew was killed in the line of
duty um he was a SWAT deputy sheriff and
also US Army Combat veteran but most
importantly to me he was my friend and
as we were sitting at his funeral um
they performed what's called an End of
Watch call ceremony it's where a
dispatcher calls for the deputy but the
call goes unanswered there's just
silence um but however once they finish
the call they play The deputy's Voice um
with the quote saying End of Watch which
means all is well and as I heard
Andrew's previous recorded voice close
the ceremony with code four um I just
felt a a feeling overwhelming feeling of
Peace come over me uh but most
importantly uh an overwhelming feeling
to take action so as my wife and I were
driving home from the funeral we decided
that we were going to do something
special for Andrew's family because we
didn't want them to feel like they were
alone um and so Christmas was Andrew's
favorite holiday so we decided that we
were going to pay for Christmas for his
family so when the Christmas season
rolled around uh we made we got them a
beautiful Christmas tree delivered it
right to their doorstep uh we bought
amazing ffield gifts um that reminded
them of their father and the great you
know experience they had with Andrew uh
we had a beautiful Christmas dinner
delivered to their house um so they
didn't have to worry about you know the
time and work it takes to prepare that
dinner and you know I'm an American
Soldier like Andrew was and my wife's a
school teacher you know so money doesn't
necessarily uh come easily at our house
however because of what you all have
taught we have multiple side hustles and
one of those side hustles is actually a
very successful uh like you know vintage
8s themed and modern collectible store
in our mall and so because of the
profits that we make from that store we
were able to provide Christmas for
Andrew's family not only last year but
this year as well wow and I just wanted
to just wanted to say you know as an
American Soldier I am constantly
bombarded with people you know thank you
for your service and all these heartfelt
thanks I'm very grateful for it but I
was hoping sir if I could ask all the
Ramsey listeners to maybe think of the
heroes that are closer to Hess year you
know they're all around us and they're
the ones who will come running towards
danger to protect us while all others
run away yep and they're willing to give
their ultimate sacrifice in order to
save our lives like my friend Andrew did
so if uh you they're our protectors and
they're the law enforcement verse
responders so if I could just ask
everybody to please thank them and and
uh for that blank of protection they
provide each and every day I'd I'd
appreciate that amen amen well said and
if he was SWAT he was running straight
towards Danger
yes sir he was he was in this case there
was a a shots fired call and and um he
was one of the first officers there and
and without hesitation uh ran straight
into the uh to the fry wow well his
legacy lives on so thank you for sharing
that story with with us and millions of
listeners Shane that's powerful yes sir
absolutely I appreciate you giving me
the time to honor Legacy absolutely
absolutely what city was he in uh
Colorado Springs College where you live
okay all right very good sir very cool
well thank you for who you are and yes
thank you for your service and uh but
thank you for the generosity story uh I
mean that's that's a guy that um that
all of us look up to he's he's he's a a
man that you want to step in and help
his family and I'm really glad that
someone actually did it instead of just
thought of it uh good intentions don't
get you much of anything the actual
actions are what what caus it and
generosity is the same way you can't
just intend to do it you've actually got
to go do it and you did it Shane so
thank you for doing that there there's
thoughts and prayers and then there's
gifting the entire family some really
thought filled gifts on top of thoughts
and prayers what about an envelope of
cash what about covering the gifts this
let's let's do a little more with some
action involved and uh that's an
inspiring story right there yeah show up
with some car keys for somebody that's
carless and have the car too by the way
but yeah that helps somebody that
doesn't have a car and that would be a
cruel joke though just to bring the key
keys for you no that would be no we're
not doing that no give them the car to
that go with the keys but yeah I mean do
some stuff like that it's amazing how
much car you can buy for four or 5,000
bucks even 2,000 bucks um so I mean and
you can go you know you if you go buy
five or 10 of them you can you can get a
deal oh yeah what's amazing to me is
when you're not worried about your bills
you can worry about other people's bills
there's a piece of getting out of debt
where you get to look up and out at
Opportunity because you're not so self
focused and if it's not you this year if
you're in struggling this year and and
this is your year to turn things around
and get to be that guy someday that's
okay you're supposed to take care of
your own household first are you're
worse than unbeliever that's scriptural
then yeah we take care of now then we
take care of then start thinking about
the future and that's taking care of
your household as well then we think
about us our family making sure our
family's taken care of and that's
generationally changing things and then
them that's community and you'll work
through that progression as your wealth
increases and your quality of management
of that wealth increases it's a natural
thing that occurs this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the Ramsey Christmas Cash
giveaway is ending soon the last day to
enter is Wednesday December the 20th you
could win the grand prize of
$5,000 enter every day to increase your
chances of winning ramsy solutions.com
giveaway this is our annual giving show
so that kind of fits in we're talking
with a gentleman at the break from
Louisville Kentucky they started a
giving Club
25 years ago there's uh 10 people in the
club and they give $300 each twice a
year okay so $3,000 twice a year
$6,000 each time per annual and done
that for 25 years and the number of
things they have seeded and inspired
particularly with Habitat homes he said
was absolutely amazing um that's an
interesting way to put some money
together with other people um I guess if
you're in the club you have to have a
bylaws on deciding on how the money is
going to be given
uh and that way and you're comfortable
with that to put your 300 in right we
didn't ask him about that but I assume
that would be true he's given us a
thumbs up giving us a thumbs up telling
us that that is true that's a cool
idea make it a tradition for 2 years you
know if you got 300 bucks it's a way to
create
3,000 yeah that's a little little
different lift right and do some really
cool things in your community and Beyond
very good stuff Thomas is with us in
Oklahoma City Thomas tell us your giving
story hey guys good afternoon thanks for
having me on what an honor honor to be
with you sir Merry Christmas tell us the
story okay so um about a year ago we we
got a we had a fellow contractor um that
found out that um that he died and so
then we got a phone call from a
potential client we went out and visited
with the client and through discuss
discussion we found out that um that
this fellow was actually on that project
when he went went home to take a nap and
passed away whoa and so we got with our
um fellow members of the Oklahoma City
decorative concrete Association and we
actually all decided that we wanted to
take this project on and see how we
could help the the Widow and so went out
and met with the potential client asked
him if we could take on this project
finish it up doing an epoxy floor and um
if he would then write the check for the
ing balance on on the the job to the
Widow and so we came to an agreement
that he would do that one of the
contractors supplied the material we
supplied all the labor it took about six
days to do the project finished it all
up and then at the end we um we went and
presented the check to the Widow and her
three kids and they were just you know
completely blown away it was a little
over $8,000 all right wow very cool and
all took was a little bit of creativity
and six days of work y yeah and well and
somebody furnish the materials on the
other side too but yeah yeah right and
um what was really neat is even our guys
on on on our crew they actually came up
to me when they found out about the
project and they they asked if they
could work for free or for half their
their um hourly wages which we didn't
allow them to do that but I thought that
was really neat that they wanted to be
part of it in that way as well
wow love it love it way to go guys wow
very cool so this guy was a he was a
concrete sub is what you're saying yeah
yeah um decorative concrete so we do
like epoxy coatings or polished concrete
things like that and that's what he did
as well yeah and um and yeah I guess he
you know he was battling with with Co
and his guys were on the job doing the
project he went home you know and uh
during that time he he took a nap and I
and suffered a heart attack and just
didn't make it through
yeah so you know we we were just we felt
the calling you know we've done some
projects like this where where we've
reached out to the community and and
helped out some schools and different
things but this one was this one really
hit home because it was such a personal
level and he was a fellow contractor
yeah yeah just right there in the
neighborhood oh my gosh wow very good
idea Thomas how old are
you um I'm 37 my brother and business
partner is uh uh 43 how long you been in
business uh since 2008 so I right after
high school for me and um and he was a
little older than that and we just kind
of learned it and went from there I
suspect you're going to continue to
prosper well done sir and you probably
Inspire that whole crew to even be more
generous with their time and their
talent and their money well the thing is
you can uh be kind to someone be
generous to someone and it affects that
person but it is impossible for you to
do that and not affect other people
simultaneously cuz someone somewhere is
watching even if you don't want them to
be even if you're trying to keep it
secret someone saw that happen and it it
inspired them it changed them it caused
them to think you know the check out the
girl checking out the groceries you know
if you pay for the Bucky in front right
you just pay it forward it inspires the
person doing the checkout inspires the
person that got the free groceries but
also inspires the person doing the
checkout they're never the same no it
generosity shapes reshapes people's
brains and they can never return to the
same shape once you've witnessed it once
you've been part of it uh it it it
there's a chemistry that's completely
different than spending completely
different than enjoyment of money on a
fun thing yourself uh or saving up and
you know getting something you've worked
really hard for all of those things are
fine there's nothing wrong with that at
all we teach that all the time but it
doesn't reshape your brain what reshapes
your brain is witnessing and
participating in in generosity well
we've always said money amplifies who
you are it's a magnifying glass but
what's interesting is that generosity
changes who you are and that's what's so
powerful about it it's not necessarily
the you know the immorality of money but
it's what you do with it and when you
give it away it affects you way more
than just hanging on to it spending it
having a good time and I think that's
increased I know it is just from
personal experience I don't I don't have
data on this but just antidot it's
increased dram atically when there's a
personal element to it so like uh the
filming that we showed in in another
hour of you going into the Waffle House
and giving giving each of the staff
members 500 bucks and then one lady who'
had a particularly hard year giving her
$2,000 um you were up close in person I
mean she's crying we catch it on camera
of course but you you're you get the hug
you know she's you know everybody's
watching all of this the in the whole
freaking waffle house I mean it's a it's
a show going on in a sense and so that
reshapes everyone that is within
touching distance of that that's a
little different than mailing a check to
XYZ hitting the button on the website
which is still great there's nothing
wrong with that but you're losing that
personal experience for sure yeah I mean
we just had a bunch of tornadoes north
of Nashville up in the Clarksville area
a bunch of homes destroyed and uh yeah
you can send money there through XYZ
that that if there it's a good XYZ um
but there's a little difference the
buddy of ours that has a church up there
um and they're on the ground cleaning up
trash they're showing up cleaning up
trash and helping people find the you
know the the kids stroller four four
blocks over and all this kind of stuff
it's crazy what goes on with a tornado
but yeah the there there's a thing that
happens when you're there and you
witness it in person the person
receiving it um or the person giving it
for that matter uh if you just watch it
happen it it's a lot different than
hitting submit on a website it's the
same thing true of of of ordering you
know of buying something that you go
into a store you touch it you feel it
you think about it there's a sensory
there's a sensory thing and then you
make the decision to buy it's a lot
different than I think it might fit
let's see if it doesn't they can allow
me to return it you hit click click
right it's a different thing we've lost
that for sure in a digital age so that's
a good reminder when you're giving find
ways to make it personal well you don't
have to do your whole budget that way I
mean you don't have to walk up and you
know hand your tithe check to the
preacher each Sunday and
go you know you don't have to do that
man that be just turn that thing in
right but but the uh but occasionally if
you're going to do something for someone
just do it in person it's just whacked
um sometimes the sometimes the reaction
is weird uh it's almost always a little
bit of Awkward Moment around it you've
experienced that oh yeah it can be very
awkward but it's always worth it and
just because the person doesn't know how
to respond doesn't make it any less
powerful y exactly exactly takes their
breath away literally uh yeah that can
happen I promise you this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today he's also the author of
the brand new book Breaking Free from
broke uh you can get it in the ramsy
solution store or well at least you can
get the uh pre-order of it it will
actually come out in January uh it's
only $20 to pre-order it and you get
$100 in bonus items including his newest
talk show me the money wonder where you
got that title and and exclusive access
to an online private event and a Q&A
with George audio book and the ebook if
you pre-order you get all of that for
just 20 bucks uh the book is Breaking
Free from broke he exposes the most
common money myths and excuses head on
like credit card schemes investing traps
mortgage myths all the stuff you wish
you've been taught in high school
pre-order it at ramsy solutions.com
sstore George I just got an email a few
minutes ago that the book is uh the
pre-sales on it are outstanding their
breaking records wow that's good news it
is good news well I appreciate
everyone's support of it on you know
I've been getting a lot of messages and
DMS people are excited about it they
listen to We release an audiobook
preview and we're doing something fun
with the audiobook I know I've been
listening to the enhancements some sound
design your not your mama's audio book
this is I got some cool stuff in it I
can't do anything normal it's a toxic
tradeit of mine I just have to be a
little extra this is our giving show
today we're taking uh calls from those
of you that are recipients or the
givers in something that's inspiring and
generous the phone number is
88255 225 Harrison in Connecticut says
when I was a kid in the early 2000s my
dad had an old Tahoe for sale at the
bottom of the driveway he got a call
from someone inquiring to purchase the
car it was it was an expectant father
with very little money my Dad decided to
GI the car to him at this time old you's
cars weren't worth much they aren't now
and my dad used this opportunity to show
us kids how to be charitable and kind to
strangers good years later we found out
the car is still going good very cool
Kimberly in Texas thanks to following
the Ramsay plan this year I was able to
give gift cards to all 20 of the
teachers at my son's daycare whoa as a
single mom of two I never would have
thought I'd be able to give so
abundantly and no longer have to live
paycheck to paycheck I'm so grateful to
Ramsey Solutions all that you provide to
educate on Financial Security and
freedom that's cool
wow you see the transformation there yep
she remembers living paycheck to
paycheck and now she's on the other side
yep and um taking care of the workers at
a daycare is a really good idea mhm
Jamie in Ohio our friend's
three-year-old daughter was diagnosed
with leukemia she was child number three
mom was pregnant with number four they
had to distance themselves from social
interaction to protect their daughter's
immune system my husband hband and I
over a 10 week period mailed them a $100
gift card every week from random places
gas stations grocery stores restaurants
each was sent anonymously with a word of
encouragement and scripture uh thank God
their daughters now healed and thriving
love that that's a fun idea yeah very
cool good stuff rich is in Albany New
York Rich tell us your giving story hey
guys how you doing great
man um so um I've been uh I've been
listening to you guys uh since about
August of this year and like most people
you know I got caught up and listened
and read everything I could possibly
find and one of the stories that just
kept popping with me was the uh one
about the Thanksgiving morning at the
waffle house uh and you know I just had
this feeling I was just like I can't
wait till I'm in the situation where I
can actually like do that um so as I
just kept going um and and listening I
uh I decided some point in October it's
like you know what it's I'm going to do
something this Thanksgiving morning uh
it's not going to be on that scale but
uh uh I'm going to do something so the
day before Thanksgiving I tell my uh 1y
old boy is like look uh after the gym
tomorrow we're gonna uh we're gonna hit
the Dina uh which was kind of a surprise
I mean in the morning of Thanksgiving
morning uh I mean we're going to a d uh
but he had no idea what was up uh so
after we uh after we had left the gym um
I let him choose the diner I even you
know let him choose what we going to sit
at the booth uh or table service and uh
you know I had these two $50 bills into
my pocket and uh I was going to you know
I was going to I was going to tip a
waitress so uh
$100 yes good I like this I know I did
have a little uh you know little
trepidation I mean we're dead smack in
the middle of baby step 2 uh $15,000 are
we thrown at the snowball five credit
accounts already down and so I was
thinking I was like you maybe I can use
this hundred bucks elsewhere I mean
thanks morning and I'm out of Diner and
I know I'm not ordering rice and beans
today uh and my son you know he's 17 he
was going to order like he was going to
the electric chair at
midnight so I'm thinking to myself like
I maybe just 50 bucks um so but the
waitress comes over she's in her you
know her late 50s quick reading um
drinks and you know I finally talk
myself out I was like no they said this
you know this is the most fun you can
have with money so you know we're going
to do it uh I even had it you know as a
lineup item in the every dollar app you
know 100 bucks you know it's for gobble
gobble fun uh so you know we were we
were going to do this uh so she comes
back with drinks I decided to start up
open up a little Rapport and I was like
I was like how'd you get so lucky to
work Thanksgiving morning and at this
point this is this is when God showed up
um she was like in this thick Southern
drawer that had no business being
anywhere near Aly she says oh I don't
mind honey I live here alone all my
family is back home in
Tennessee and I I couldn't believe what
I heard I mean here I am you know the
I'm trying to go through all these Ramy
steps and I'm wondering is this the you
know is this is this the the PA is is
this what I should be doing and here she
is you know a waitress a thousand miles
away from home in alany and she's from
Tennessee uh you know the last three
months is just been you know
intense uh trying to recreate this
Waffle House story and here she is my
waitress in Tennessee I mean I almost
hand for the $50 bills right there we
hadn't even ordered food yet
um so I mean my son could have ch chosen
any uh Diner uh I mean he could have
chose a counter uh uh you we W up at
that booth and you know it had to be her
it was her uh so I mean the whole meal I
was just you know I was in like I knew
this this was God's work this was like
you know the light um so we we paid the
bill um she came back and you know I
reached in my pocket I handed her $2 $50
and you know she was she was flored too
I mean she her eyes kind of said you
know I can't take this U but you know I
just I said thanks for the breakfast I
guess not all of us New Yorkers are bad
um and I I don't know if she needed the
money but I know I needed her uh after
that U it was worth a heck of a lot more
than $100 I mean um um so we got back
into the car I explained the story to my
son and you know why it was just you
know so crazy that this waitress was was
from Tennessee uh and you know he he's
been listening you know it's been going
in the background for months you know
your your podcast your stories you know
everything my they're getting books for
Christmas they have no idea it's in it's
in their stockings George's book is you
know is it will be here in January uh so
uh they know that I'm all in so when I
explained it to him he was just like y
we should do this every Thanksgiving I
was like the diner or the giving and uh
she's like no no they they're giv I was
like yeah I think it's uh I think that's
really cool if you're damn right
absolutely absolutely that's exactly the
way that works well done Rich beautiful
well played more is caught than taught
and that kid he caught that he caught
dad being generous and said that's what
I want to do I'm going to be generous
cuz some hillbilly in Tennessee is
saying to be generous and then shows up
in his waitress is from Tennessee it's
like God saying told you that's amazing
told you no $50 here $100 dump them both
out there buddy I love I I think we need
more callers from Albany I love that
accent well he loves ours so there you
go something for everyone in the story
that's a lot of fun well done rich I
love it well played actually the truth
is that guy sent that email in oh that's
Custom Care I read that in our staff
meeting to I read uh I read hate mail on
our staff meeting and I read uh brag
stuff in our staff meeting both just to
inspire our team they like both actually
I like his version of it though with the
accent it really sells the story better
A lot better than me reading in his
voice it's EXA a lot better yeah you get
the upstate New York feel adds to it is
awesome very cool this is our annual
giving show here on the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of today Proverbs 11:25 a
generous person will prosper whoever
refreshes others will be
refreshed Maya Angelo says when we give
cheerfully and accept
gratefully everyone is blessed oh that's
good well done all right Sarah is with
us on our giving show today hi Sarah in
Nashville tell us your giving
story so um I got to call in back in
August and get some uh some help with my
mortgage and someone heard my story and
offered to help the kids and I with our
mortgage and they are from Murphysboro
they actually when I spoke to the guy
Nate Burns he had told me that I knew
his sister-in-law and he explained to me
that his sister-in-law knew me and had
heard my story on your show also she was
the donor liaison who held my hand and
walked me through the organ donating
process when my husband passed away and
um she's the one that's been in contact
with us every year annually about our
organ recipients and how they're doing
and the lives that my husband was able
to save and give a second chance and the
way the whole situation took full circle
it was it was very it was a phenomenal
experience wow it was just it was wild
okay so I'm just now catching on and I
make sure our audience catches on as
well Sarah called in um back in the
summer and was about to be foreclosed on
uh we took her call John delone and I
did George had Sarah on a few weeks ago
to revisit that um but when you called
in your house you owed like $65,000 it's
worth 300,000 and it was 45 days from
being foreclosed on only need about
$3,000 to be current and a bunch of
things have happened around Sarah's life
since then one was the house was brought
current uh two another listener donated
her car her husband was 36 years old and
fell through a roof he was a roofer and
passed away and now you're saying his uh
when that happened he he had uh planned
to donate his organs and the liaison was
ended up being the cousin of the guy who
sent you the money to catch your house
up the sister-in-law the sister-in-law
wow his wife's sister oh my gosh okay
this just keeps having layers to it wow
it was it was amazing like I I get
goosebumps every time I tell this story
because it it it it restore a faith in
me that I so desperately needed okay so
she helped you walk through the process
of your husband 36 years old passing
donating his organs and then she heard
you on the air behind behind and
recognized your
voice yeah she recognized my last name
and and I we didn't have your last name
on the
air well no when they found me they
found me on Facebook um to tell me they
wanted to help with the house and um I
had commented on the post that it was me
and that you know he could reach out to
me and his sister-in-law seen my name
and was like oh I know her and when I
talked to Nate he was like you know my
sister-in-law Aaron and I was like I
don't think so and he told me how I knew
her and I was like oh my God I do know
her I do I know her well wow that is a
full circle that's amazing yeah okay it
was awesome there's a lot of that's wild
a lot of intricacy to this generosity
it's going everywhere yeah we need a new
segment called small world big God how
about that that's pretty cool Sarah
that's
amazing we love hearing from you our
whole team has been cheering you on and
praying for you and you you uh you got a
special place in our heart for sure and
America's heart you guys are Forever
part of our family we are so grateful
for you guys and everything that you do
not only for us but for everybody that
listens to you guys you're such a
blessing well thank you Sarah good to
talk to you again and Merry Christmas
thanks for calling in to sharing the
another Circle this story story just
keeps I see on our screen it says eight
lives were saved from his organ
donations how cool is that wow that's
amazing Lisa is in Scott City Kansas hi
Lisa tell us your generosity
story hey well I'm not sure I can top
that one that was pretty one's uh
there's a lot going on there I don't
think anybody can top that one that's
okay it's not a competition well mine
is it been October 2022 my kids all
wanted to go to church camp and it was
way more than I could really
afford so they were actually they
started I told them well get an envelope
write can of cook on it and start saving
your money doing it the Dave Ramy way
and so they all did and I said I'll help
you throughout the year we'll come up
with ways to save money how many kids
three three okay three high school kids
okay yeah so they were making decorated
sugar cookies to sell at Halloween time
and they had sold a ton and so ID helped
helped them over the weekend and we were
delivering cookies like all Saturday
night Sunday and Sunday at church a man
just came up to me I was busy talking
with someone else and he's like hey I
stuck something in your in your Bible
and I thought he was paying me for some
cookies that he had gotten so I didn't
even look at it finished church went
home started cooking lunch and while I
was cooking lunch I thought oh I should
get that check out of my Bible before I
forget about it so my kids can count it
because they were keeping track of who
they've delivered to who's paid and I
opened it up and it was a check for
$5,000 oh
my I just I mean it makes me cry right
now it was enough with what they had
already earned and saved to like
completely pay for all of them to go to
church camp the next summer
wow so I took it out there and I showed
like for you guys and like gave me at
church this
morning and while I'm crying they have
like the biggest Smiles on their faces
cuz I'm like you can go like you're
going you're going to church
camp so
I was just like overwhelmed with
gratitude and
just I I just can't even explain it or
just somebody like giving you a gift
like that that's amazing take care of
something that's a lot of money it is it
is a lot of money yes and I'm living on
a teacher salary so that is a lot of
money wow wow very cool very good story
thank you for Shing that sharing that
Lisa that is amazing it's fun the kids
are working towards something and then
God says okay I'll help I got you wow I
got this my face hurts for sure this
hour Dave I don't know about you but my
mouth muscles from smiling this much it
feels good and it's definitely inspiring
I see why you held this a tradition on
the Ramsey show Kelly in California we
encourage our seven-year-old son to
think about those that are less
fortunate for his birthday he wanted his
friends to bring donations for the
Humane Society rather than gifts we
included this message in his invitation
he ended up collecting an entire cart
full of pet toys food beds blankets The
Joy he received from giving his gifts to
the animals is something he continues to
talk about I asked him if he wanted to
choose another organization this year
and his answer was this is a hard
decision I know that I would really love
to get a lot of presents and awesome
toys for my friends but I know I can
help more animals or kids than maybe
some people so uh I think I want to help
because that feels good boom there you
go 7 years old it gets it if a
seven-year-old can get it I think any
adult can should man well it's fun Dave
there's on the every dollar budget you
have giving right underneath income it's
the first line item was that intentional
on your part well you're giving for
those people that are people of Faith
like we are it's first fruits it's off
the top the first thing you do is tithe
the first thing you do is give offering
and before you do anything else it's not
leftovers no it's um everything else is
left over after the giving just to kind
of get that rhythm in your life to start
to build that generosity muscle and uh
the interesting thing is the more you do
it um like any other habit or character
trait uh the more refined it becomes the
stronger your generosity muscle gets uh
you're more Discerning you're careful uh
and your gifts are more effective uh and
you know first time or two you know 30
years ago we started doing this stuff we
were a bit sloppy at it but now it's
very refined your heart was there but
the uh yeah but you know you look back
you go that was kind of weird but yeah
you know but we did it anyway right you
know but uh but you really can't mess
this up it's impossible to mess it up uh
because somebody on the other side
doesn't think you messed it up so uh Hey
guys getting gear that's what the season
is all about good reminders the giving
portion of what we teach is it's there
uh and the reason it's number one in and
number one line item in the budget is to
remind you know God is the ultimate
giver and that's what we're reminded of
at Christmas he gave his only begotten
son
that you might have everlasting life
there you go that puts us hour the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the mean
time remember there is ultimately only
one way to financial peace and that's to
walk daily with the Prince of Peace
Christ
[Music]
Jesus
you